this is so hard y'all
thank you thank you thank you thank you
for the energy that everyone has brought
here today
the celebration of how great
we all know dmx was
what he has left behind dmx was honored
at a celebration of life memorial
where friends and family paid tribute to
the late rapper
and now i'm really sad
because we have lost a icon
and the best father anybody can ask for
on saturday the private service was held
at barclays center and was
live streamed to dmx's youtube channel
[Music]
kanye west appeared with his sunday
service choir they opened the ceremony
with a medley of emotional performances
many of dmx's friends and collaborators
attended the service
where they reflected on his life and
legacy
i am seriously the
luckiest luckiest woman in the world to
have been adopted by the rough riders
but to have
known dmx the way that i knew him
as a man a father a friend
that's my brother we did a great movie
together
and on that movie he was just
rising up as a star he looked at me
and tears in his eyes
because he knew about the journey he was
about to embark on
becoming a hip-hop icon
leading up to the ceremony the rapper's
casket was driven in the back of a
monster truck which had
long lived dmx written on the side the
procession began
in yonkers where dmx was raised and
later arrived in brooklyn
where an enormous crowd had gathered
outside barclays center
the sheer crowd of people out here just
shows the impact that dmx had on a
number of his fans we're talking
hundreds and hundreds of people
standing outside of the barclays center
right now some of them traveling out of
state
just to say their final goodbye kanye
who also produced the service
showed footage of dmx leading his sunday
service choir for easter in 2019.
may we be heard and understood from the
suburbs
to the hood may you judge us by our
hearts
and not by our mistakes and see that we
get our breakthrough
however long that it takes at the end of
the memorial swizz beatz paid his
respects with a tribute to one of the
rapper's most
memorable songs
[Music]
you